be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
all right people we are here and let me
learn the material some understanding
understand it up in my recording space
right now I'm not even next to the
microphone man like this soundproof room
I'm standing in here and I've got the
chair in my hand we are now we are here
we are here at the conclusion of powers
of x3 awesome this is a man of chaos
this is why I love Jonathan Hickman man
is because you're like like you read
Jonathan you read Jonathan Hickman
stories and it's like man I have it all
figured out and I know what's going on
and then he's like no you don't either
like it it's it's if God was riding the
x-men right now this is what it would
look like right now
it's it's it's amazing okay so so this
picks up your honor I'm so excited to
come this picks up initially the exact
same way powers of X number one picked
up and this is awesome I love the way
that Hickman does this because it's one
of these I love the most about Jonathan
Hickman right like everything kind of
wraps around and that's why I like house
and powers of X is for the most part
self-contained but at the same time it
also continues on especially with the
way everything popped off right so this
starts off basically like back in the
day right like x-men here zero is really
what what Jonathan Hickman calls it and
it picks up with more McTaggart
basically meeting with Charles Xavier
now a lot of what you saw in powers of X
number one is the exact same here right
like house of powers of X number one
it's pretty much the exact same and so
far as like more McTaggart sits down she
basically greets Charles Xavier somebody
that he that she knows exhibit doesn't
know who she is and then she's just kind
of like well read my mind and find out
what's going on and so what we do is we
jump to the year of x-men we could win
jobs a year 1000 with the x-men now this
was the point in the story and in
Hitman's writing we had ascension right
this idea that somewhere along the line
from what hitman was kind of showing us
what seemed to be going on is that you
had man and machine which basically
merged right the idea of nano signals
that initially you had signals created
by man and then signals created Nimrods
and then in turn they started eventually
creating nanobots red they could
basically attach themselves to humans
and then convert humans into sentinels
which really came out of like fashion
right when when nimrod would a single
nimrod machine merged with the master
mold that was back in the 90s that was
long before
when showed up but he kind of took that
concept of him threw it in there so it's
like okay cool you know I get what's
going on here
and then as a result to that essentially
like humanity and robots whatever it was
they basically achieved a level of
ascension what we're getting here is
nothing like what we thought it was and
I was like dude this is amazing like
this is this is awesome because once you
have the librarian write this this guy
that we'd seen in the previous in the
previous videos when the librarian
enters into the preserve right this kind
of like giant makeshift cage more or
less and animals and different things
like that of course none of its real and
he's immediately attacked by one of his
inhabitants and he basically says like
how many times are you going to do this
like you're a primitive beast right like
by the time you realize what you wanted
to do I already prepared countermeasures
right my mind is far beyond yours like
you just relentlessly attacking makes
you look like a buffoon and this is when
we find out the person the librarian of
talking to you is Wolverine he's been
alive for a thousand years and it's like
dude he hasn't really aged that much
right now this is an accurate depiction
of Wolverine right like how we saw
Wolverine appear in old man Logan
it was probably stressed technically
speaking Wolverine should not look like
he aged that much in the span of 50
years it's also kind of an interesting
date here because one of the things that
hikmah kind of silently did when it came
to house and powers of X is that when he
resurrected Wolverine II and you guys
caught on to this like that you caught
on to it faster than I did but when
house the powers of X went when
Wolverine was resurrected the
implication seemed to be he didn't have
adamantium in his bones right he'd never
adamantium bonded to himself he just
came back at his most pure form with
bone claws but like this conversation
between the two is is really really
interesting because what Wolverine says
is that like these individuals here like
basically these mutants inside that's
preserved they want to be free like they
want freedom and the responsive
librarian is these mutants don't know
what freedom is because for the most
part aside from you and the other they
were born inside this cage this is the
only world they know so how could they
possibly understand the notion of
freedom if they don't know their cage in
the first place and the responsible
rayna's because I've been telling them
because I've been teaching them about
revolution and I've been telling them
about the world outside this cage and
they want something better they want
something more right and under normal
circumstances if Wolverine hadn't been
there this would have been their world
oh so it was kind of a crazy thing
because what the librarian says is I
wasn't waiting on you I was waiting on
her only for them to be met with the
arrival of Moreh McTaggart more
McTaggart has apparently been alive all
this time like she's been in this future
this entire time and we don't know what
she's been doing we somebody just know
that she's been there and it's kind of
the crazy thing because what we get is
this
full-on explanation of what's going on
but I mean the librarian basically tells
and the Phalanx are here we're going to
merge our essences with the phalanx and
they're in turn gonna enter a black hole
and our entire collective consciousness
is going to be dumped into one of those
big black holes super gods whatever it
is and that's gonna be it right I mean
it's kind of like a higher state of
entropy more or less their physical
forms will vanish and that will
basically be it and it kind of comes as
a shock you know a little bit too to
both the more MacTaggert Anto will ring
right like the world is going to end it
kind of comes as a shock to them and
it's interesting here because what it
does what the librarian does is
basically answer almost all the
questions that we've had yet when when
the librarian look Sam you taneema t'v
life-form right like how funny it is
that you thought you were going to be
the next step in human evolution and for
the most part they were they aren't
right as they're naturally occurring
that's so that's what the the librarian
says mutants are a naturally occurring
phenomena therefore they're kind of like
nature's response to the evolutionary
change but at the end of the day is all
rooted in the notion that light at any
point nature could have snuffed it out
right I mean that was kind of the whole
idea when the Celestials modified the
genes of early man and they planted in
place an idea that these genes would
manifest at a single point in time
nature could have rejected that was the
grand experiment of the Celestials will
make sure go alongside it will make you
reject it will it basically start
exercising these genes out of the
various humans that are procreating or
they'll just never activate but because
of the fact that they're the next stage
in human evolution Newton's always sort
of saw themselves this way what's
librarian says is that's not true the
librarian is indeed human but he's an
evolved human it's really kind of how
they progress and it's sort of funny
because in the face of all this we were
kind of like okay so basically humans
and machines merged and like singular
entities and basically humans were more
or less wiped out and so we're so we're
mutants for the most part I mean what's
left of the mutant population is living
in a Preserve somewhere that's what the
indications seem to be what we're being
told here is that in response to the
mutant threat and the the the increase
in the mutant population the humanity in
an act of desperation basically started
modifying the genes of other humans the
idea was that humans and machines same
assembly merged together and then
ultimately started creating supermen and
that's that's really the response here
is of what concerned were mutants to
humans when humans could basically start
using biological engineering and create
superhumans of their own and so as a
result of that it seemed as though of
war more or less broke out between
humans and mutants and ultimately humans
won and so it's kind of a crazy thing
because like you see this and it's just
like wow like we lost the entire time
warm attack
they didn't know that and so one of the
cool things that come out of this is
that you actually end up learning that
like wolverine does have adamantium
bonded to his bones right so like he's
returned with adamantium and we're not
really given an explanation here where
somebody just totally has adamantium in
his bones
and so in response to this the librarian
does not initially want to kill more
McTaggart and the reason why is because
in and you'll be taking them into
whatever this conscious state is going
to be and then keeping them there for
all eternity it would mean that more
McTaggart would never truly die and
because she would never truly die she
would never be reborn as her past self
and then be able to stop this future
from happening and so it's kind of funny
here because the librarian ultimately
leaves and then Wolverine does what he
does best and more of a tiger basically
says kill me so I can go back I can be
reborn and we can stop this future from
happening
Wolverine kills more McTaggart and thus
ends the sixth life of more McTaggart I
was like dude this was her sixth life
and it's dude it's it's crazy like it's
it's nuts because it's like okay
everybody's been wanting to know what
the sixth life of Mora McTaggart is like
some of you guys had theories that like
it was Inferno somehow she was involved
in the events of inferno maybe like the
one who kind of prompted and pushed
Madeline prior to just kind of go crazy
and make a deal with demons by whatever
the case is like there were all kinds of
theories right that like more McTaggart
like the the person running the show is
not Charles Xavier that is actually more
on the counter like everybody had
theories on this and it was so cool and
I think that like everyone was wrong I
haven't seen all the theories so I don't
know but it's kind of crazy because
witness information kind of jumping back
to the moment when Xavier was reading
the mind of Maura McTaggart witness
information which calls Xavier learns is
the x-men always lose in every single
circumstance the x-men always lose in
these dystopian futures it always plays
out the same way and it's the coolest
thing ever right because this has all
really been spearheaded by the events of
like Days of Future past that story that
Marvel created back in the day set the
stage for like dystopian futures and in
in you know regarding the mutant
population and even a superhuman
population as a whole in terms of
humanity versus mutants and ever since
then has always been this kind of notion
that like it seems them he was always
loosed and all the lives that were
McTaggart slipped and all the
experiences that she's had whether she's
been on the side of apocalypse who waged
his war against what was the left of
humanity and evolves humans of whatnot
flat against Nimrod all that kind of
stuff in every single one of these lives
mutants
always end up lose it right they always
end up Harrison and that's kind of the
funny thing is because in response to
this Xavier is like well there's still a
chance for us to come out on top there's
still a chance for us to win here and
it's one of the funny things because you
get these sort of journal entries from
war I'm encountered right we're not
gonna cover them all but we get these
kind of journal entries from more in the
taggert and what she does is she starts
going through and basically highlighting
a lot of the things that we've already
seen but doing it from her perspective
right so like they've recruited magneto
magneto could be a lot more ruthless and
Charles Xavier camp but she also is is
really kind of having this discussion of
like this kind of revelation of the
truth to Charles Xavier Avenger this ham
will come when he will have to walk away
from this idealized perspective of the
world well you have to walk away from
the notion of how he wants the world to
be and focus on the way the world
actually is right like stepping into
reality and so it's a cool thing because
what it does is it sort of highlights
this idea that between the time at war
make had it first encountered Xavier or
at least visited him at the beginning of
the story at the beginning of house and
powers of X up until now in the modern
day there's been a gradual progression
where Xavier has kind of become a little
more extreme but I kind of walked away
from this idea that we can find a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
mutants and instead has basically come
to the realization humans can't be fixed
there cannot be any kind of peaceful
coexistence because of every single
attempt to create one it inevitably
fails right because humanity gets scared
they ultimately create like arms and
armament they go through whatever steps
they need to even artificially
engineering and improving on themselves
in order to destroy the mutant threat it
always plays out that way it's
essentially one of these things where
Xavier sort of comes to a realization
that Magneto's known his entire life
that humanity cannot and should not be
trusted and you have to move forward
accordingly and so it's really crazy
here because following this what you end
up doing is you end up having Xavier and
Magneto who sit down with more macabre
and say here's where everything stands
right now right I mean the things that
we've basically seen so far the quiet
council has been formed which is to say
the governing body of the mutant
population and more McTaggart really
seems to look at it from the perspective
of the work isn't done yet but the
reality of where magneto and Xavier
coming from is that's true but you have
to relish the small successes here like
with your work an hour hour really kind
of going forward and despite the fact
that we did things you weren't supposed
to do like getting mr. sinister on board
things like that what we've done is
create a safe space for the mutant
population we've created a kind of a
government unto ourselves that humans
don't need to come to that they they
really should not and cannot come to
we've engineered our own method of
infrastructure in terms of economic
growth and
terms of social policies in the form of
government we've basically created our
own island nation now the funny thing
about this is like the same thing was
done with Genosha right as safe-haven
magneto literally held the world hostage
in order to get Genosha and ultimately
he did and then it took one mutant lay
it took it took it took Cassandra Nova
showing up with wild signals
and like that in the blink of an eye 16
million em were gone
right so all it takes is one person one
thing to essentially find the [ __ ] in
the armor to bring the whole thing
crashing down and so it's really really
cool there in terms of the possibilities
they can come out of this but at the
moment the mutant population doesn't
care the mutant population is is
celebrating everything that's going on
they're enjoying this moment and so it's
kind of a funny thing is because what
they talk about is they had to make
concessions right they had to make deals
that they otherwise wouldn't have made
one of them was with mystique and this
is one of the coolest things in order to
get mystique onto the quiet council
Charles Xavier and Magneto had you
agreed to bring destiny back and that's
a huge thing right like destiny do
destinies diaries I really hope we get
Destiny's Diaries back oh my god dude
that'd be so cool des amis Diaries were
a plot device in Marvel Comics there was
basically kind of involved a series of
stories where destiny had written down
these these like like these possible
futures these possible outcomes and it
was kind of like this mad dash to stop
him from happening it was a really cool
concept that Marvel never really did
anything with after it was all said and
done largely because destiny was dead
and even the Diaries came out after
destiny was dead after after she was
killed off but destiny is a mutant who
can see the future she's a Precog
it's not an absolute thing but it's
still a relatively strong thing and more
McTaggart is kind of terrified of this
right because she's like look if destiny
is brought back then she'll tell
everybody the fact that like we always
end up losing and so what it seems like
is the entirety of the quiet council and
the entirety of the mutant island of
cacoa is really built on deception it's
built on this idea that all these
mutants were told this will be your safe
haven this will be a place where you can
reside and not have to worry about the
threat of humanity but what seems to
have happened here is that krakoa always
plays out the same way krakoa is
established by the mutant population
that is used by the mutant population as
its own nation and then somewhere on the
line by whatever manner in whatever
means which changes based on the life of
[ __ ] the taggert war breaks out between
humans and mutants and mutants are
eradicated right so chroma is a safe
haven only insofar that humans have not
attacked it yet but ultimately they will
always end up losing and none of the
mutants on kokoa know this this is so
deceptive it's not like Charles Xavier
to do this right that's
like this new version of Charles Xavier
is a nation I love the idea of Charles
Xavier becoming a new version of himself
right it's awesome because I'm tired of
the same old thing I'd like to Charles
Xavier
Astor after house of him when he was
basically a dick and like he was cast
out of his own x-men team and the whole
thing was led by Cyclops dude like the
x-men after a house of em was amazing
it's cool to see that like the x-men are
finally getting their due diligence
right it's cool to see but the x-men are
finally getting like back to prominence
man because then we get dawn of X and
dawn of X ok check this out
it's part like you get you get dawn of X
like the actual launch like the relaunch
of the whole new x-men thing we get
x-men number one or we get an x-men
title we get a Marauders title which I
am so hyped about because Marauders are
the henchmen of mr. sinister and I've
been a fan of him for a long long time
we get the return of Excalibur which
yeah it's kind of cool we get x-force
just we get new mutants it's really cool
we'll see how it goes and we get fallen
angels I'm gonna what the hell that's
about but I'm curious to find out I
haven't looked at any of the
solicitations because I don't want to
spoil anything for myself but I'm hyped
like I'm very very excited he's not
mature some 25 years I'm so hurt man
it's huh man I'm sorry I'm so excited
people but it is an exciting time it is
an exciting time for x-men fans
everywhere I am huh man dude I'm so high
that being said we're gonna bring this
video to an end later peace
[Music]